c'est la nouvelle coqueluche du
mouvement Maga de Donald Trump Kairi
Lake 53 ans et la favorite pour le poste
de gouverneur en Arizona
c'est l'Halloween on se déguise en mur
en combattant mais derrière chaque
costume un message sous les allures
d'une ambiance bon enfant c'est un
rassemblement politique
on distribue des bonbons et puis on
écorce au passage Ketty Hobbs la rivale
démocrate qui refuse de débattre avec
hairy take
[Musique]
adversaires cette ancienne présentatrice
de Fox News qui parle aujourd'hui de
fake news est plus policé mais livre le
même message antimigrants murale à la
frontière anti-avortement et elle ne
reconnaît pas non plus les résultats des
élections de 2020
regardez notre pays regarder l'inflation
dit-elle le prix du gaz on n'a jamais eu
ce problème avec dans notre chambre
c'est dans un climat tendu que se
déroule ces élections de mi-mandat des
vigiles armés surveillent les électeurs
qui votent par anticipation c'est légal
à trancher un juge fédérale nommée par
Donald Trump après qu'il y ait plusieurs
plaintes d'intimidation
êtes-vous intimidé par mois dit-il je
porte une arme James
est respecté
et cette vigilance est encouragée par
Mark finchen le candidat républicain au
poste de secrétaire d'État
il ne reconnaît pas les élections en de
2020 il a maintes fois répété qu'il
n'aurait jamais certifié le vote qui
donnait la victoire à Joe Biden
c'est un os peu dit-il un antisémite un
extrémiste qui a appelé à la guerre
civile
selon Edwin
démocrate on n'est plus dans la partie
zannerie politique mais dans la défense
de la République
c'est donc dans ce café près de Phoenix
que s'organise une forme de résistance
républicain indépendant et démocrate se
mobilisent
les barbares sont à la porte dit-il il
est temps d'agir
j'étais en républicain jusqu'au 6
janvier dit ce pilote de l'Armée de
l'Air je fais maintenant partie des 35%
d'indépendants en Arizona
ce qui importe maintenant c'est de
maintenir notre démocratie dit-elle pour
qu'on puisse débattre à l'avenir
et c'est peut-être le calme avant la
tempête car pour beaucoup ici c'est tout
le système électoral qui est en jeu la
démocratie elle-même et on craint le
pire pour les élections présidentielles
de 2024
car dorénavant les postes clés
pourraient être détenus par des élus qui
nient les résultats de 2020
et qui cette fois pourrait avoir leur
mot à dire pour 2024 ils font donc du
porte-à-porte auprès des lecteurs
républicains avec le même message
tout sauf
keryfunction il tente de convaincre les
électeurs indépendants
étaient volées l'ancienne tout le monde
dit ça il faut pas en faire un plat
[Musique]
contrôler l'inflation et la frontière
sont ces deux priorités
wok ils vont en payer le prix
propulsé à l'avance scène grâce au
soutien de dans notre champ Kerry leek
devant sa rivale de trois points
certains prédisent même qu'elle pourrait
être sa colistière en 2024 s'il se
présente
ici Radio-Canada a fini X en Arizona